is there a toilet and the Millennium
Falcon oh I think I was cool there like
the Kanye glasses but there on the
helmet well well well huh theme Vera
grossa definitely not that what did you
think they're a Gosa you said it had an
R I know but I was being a jokester it
wasn't I don't think these they're a
jokes from the top and ashes welcome to
the show
Steve Zaragoza there she blows internet
personality yeah hi
welcome hi Jenny I know everything about
Star Wars Steve uh-huh I do name every
cantina occupant max rebo that's
hammerhead okay that's one Luke
Skywalker well
han Solo okay that's it all right Wow
yeah you do know everything about Star
Wars can I say no it'll go boop boop
so Star Wars sound did you know that
Entertainment Weekly published like a
bunch of images from the new Star while
you just get right into it don't ya I
didn't know that no no okay fake fan why
we have you on the show
I'm sorry I don't search the hashtag
Star Wars every day I've been terrible
things happening I think you know I mean
images I've seen the real one I have
been avoiding them as well I think I
felt like one on Twitter but yeah I
waited so we can look at them right now
today oh great and we're going to decide
what they all mean we're gonna glean
what we can a Star Wars movie okay from
these images right are you ready so by
the end of this episode we will have
definitively solved exactly everything
that's going to happen in the last Jedi
down to the last minute no doubts no
take-backs everything 100% accurate no
Slammys no slamming oh yeah what I
always say
are you ready to see the first image
okay okay me too oh I'm gonna Furby it's
a poor
they're like huh yeah they're the main
food source on the island is that what
Luke eats
yes okay need some in fillets heat some
in chops rolls cut some raw like sushi
okay he cuts them into thin strips and
slurps them like spaghetti do you think
they're gonna be annoying yeah yeah I
think they know what they're doing with
cuteness though yeah they made bb-8
totally work yeah it got me do you want
a pour
yes okay so I'll probably wait for this
soon soon version of a pork that's all I
want but the big size yeah so they want
to translate can I draw they made it
knowing through it's already shaped like
a tube okay put it back on the screen
counter me Craig I'm wondering why to
walk guys next to the pork okay like
broke into my bed it breaks into the
ship and there's a silly seen all our
Chewbacca bleep er yeah and the pork
like squash this is going to be the
first look at Disney's pork soon carb
tsumtsum okay I think it'll look like
that that's looking a really long time
to draw for how simple it is
thank you it's so cute though what's the
next picture Oh Rose Keiko and pin it
looks like she had her head sticking out
of the car window I know you've got
security clearance or button you know
giving you push one and she'll say hurry
up oh yeah
get to the ship yeah yeah since I asked
if it's in its muffled yeah kind of a
do you think one of her buttons
also says I hate troy'd know why shaped
wrong I know cuz up gave me like one of
hers or anything like any I don't some
snake yeah and then the other button
will say board was so cute by Paul and
then last one brush my hair yeah yes my
hair with that inflection and every
three times you press it it goes brush
my hair brush my hair brush my hair like
this is one variation in their like they
both paid yeah and then she kind of
clears her throat on the circuit doesn't
crush my hair yeah did you get it this
must be a diplomatic mission I don't
know they both look like they're giving
someone since I died I feel like this is
the scene where kylo Ren walks into the
ship and goes he's like his helmet under
his arm and he's like unreal
nice now guys I want to join your team
and their side on each other like I
can't believe that yeah and then it's
ironic because Rose is a spy for kylo
Ren yeah so I'm just saying she's a spy
she's 1,000% a spy right yeah yes all
I'm running the show
okay sure good next image please I think
this is a scene where you find out c-3po
is fine what's wrong with you
why do you think everyone was supposed
to of them good like it's a scene
between Princess Leia and like a phone
call to an admiral overlooking hello so
the mobile coffee yeah it's a phone call
and then Princess Leia's like this is
very sensitive information don't want
anyone find out and then she hangs up
the phone and then it cuts to the
shadows its c-3po he's everywhere you
know geez it's ray and Luke having a
private conversation in a cave and
they're like you know this secret Jedi
information no one will know cut the
seekers we go rey and finn having
perhaps a romantic interaction custom
seniors we go
what if Steven Rios eyes turned red when
he was angry maybe right all the time
next image
oh he likes the nuns it's the civilians
their elephant nuns I don't believe this
what we don't even have like elephants
no their elephant nuns no they worship
elephants you idiot no I know exactly
what happens in the scene oh okay okay
keep rising Holloman sing out his back
cut open coma he ended the movie in a
coma first scene in the film he wakes up
she wakes up in a panic he thinks he's
gone back to the first order it's like a
night terror he wakes up and he he pulls
all the cables off like zero he comes
out of the back to tank he's naked he's
dripping back down he's running nude
it's comedic they're playing like own
easily slide whistle like really piss
Akata okay I love this like he gets to
ship he flies out into space but he gets
sucked into a wormhole
he crash-lands on a planet ends up in
another coma and then he wakes up he's
been found by space nun and I don't see
this movie I think happens I don't work
India this is keep happening
it happens three times because rule of
three so that's the first 15 minutes of
the film okay
I think everything you said is incorrect
what I think that they're a band next
image whoa
I can't tell you what is happening in
this scene at all it just looks like a
great silly moment yeah I like to
imagine that you know they've Jedi
temples whether its temples where you
have to go through like trials yeah this
just him peeking out makes me think what
if it's a labyrinth type movie what if
she goes in the Jedi Temple and then it
was just full of poured and Muppets and
nothing but a cool film and decide what
door to go through and they sing songs
they steal on say to baka maybe it would
be Finn it would be quite demeaning but
it would be Finn I'm in yeah I'm totally
and I would love that we wearing
stretchy pajamas and then I wake up and
freak out yeah seven just rip everything
off I love you that hardware yes
next image on the screen
Oh happiest line miss my boots I love it
I'm sold me too I love it I hope there's
action in this movie could tell if
somebody's running at some point there's
like sparks okay I think this is right
before Poe gets caught on fire by those
Sparks and Bertha live in front of EPA
and he does CBS origins yeah and it's
like they're doing like a game of
Thrones thing where it's like anyone can
do and I I think the reason they're
being attacked is that kylo Ren got
really upset when he heard that bb-8 was
hanging out with Poe because bb-8 is his
droid and he's like coming to school and
greet soybean yester skate yeah okay
bb-8 running away because he didn't like
kylo Ren no it's like a custody though
true what the bb-8 loved Como he should
because kylo Ren is his father
yeah spoiler alert look out next image
whoa look at me hon it is electronic
like Tron it's like fencing red armor
doing one of those races they're
fighting the stick
I'm going to imagine the ring and this
is like it turns out that this is what
the New Jedi dressed like one is Luke
and one is Rea well I put on these
costumes oh my god Luke realized that
she doesn't know anything about Jedi he
can tell her literally anything so he's
all these dumb fancy ideas with Jedi
Order is like and he's like yeah and
they were these a red suit they look so
cool man so he convinces her and he
clearly made these himself but they look
like there's some stormtrooper stuff
happening there on the bathroom troopers
don't wear red this looks like some
samurai Tron time oh my god are these a
nice a friend hmm why are you excited
about because I like the nice over I did
yeah like I mean I think that was cool
they're like the Kanye glasses but
they're on the helmet this looks awful
okay but you're right look at the one
behind it's totally a medieval knight
helmet wait wait I say you're right I
come on my friend it's my hot page okay
they're totally the nicer rims and if
they are I don't like the nice have red
anymore
why do they look like that we'll see
it's my theory that those characters are
the Knights of Ren holds true next image
whoo it was like divergent doesn't sound
too raucous yeah yeah this looks like a
good can you do a close-up on Chewbacca
and then a close-up on Rey and Jenny and
I will do the scene okay I want to be
Chewbacca wait I want to be Chewbacca
Chewie is there a toilet on the
Millennium Falcon ah oh no what um
should I just go look for toilet what
what we've got to go save Han Solo
he's if I am seen that's where I read on
yeah yeah they're gonna go save Han Solo
yeah the guys know he felt your calories
wait yeah we gotta catch a next image
whoo
Oh Oh is this is this a continuous young
understanding from the vision in is it a
flashbacks and flash-forwards adage and
I temple is that the Jedi Temple or is
it a resistance base when the flashback
or a flash-forward because it could be
the resistance base Luke arrives to save
the day
but he's too late no no no okay no no no
no what I think this is a flashback I
think that's another valid choice yeah
and yeah against me here look at 11:00
let me lay the groundwork here I think
that what we're looking at is is Luke's
Jedi training academy and I think that
kylo Ren and the Knights of Ren that
came and tore it down and killed all of
his beggarly just the cafeteria and
killed his people they blew up the
cafeteria
no more Turkey saying I went all and
that was the only building they
completed buying them we're working all
the time because that were that he
orchestrated it it's being in the
shadows of the flames yeah yeah yeah I
think the flash dragon we're gonna have
Luke tell Ray that story and we're going
to see it all in flashback and then
raising to say it is all that amore
fishing how many we're gonna do
Oh little Benicio del Toro Horo
pretty gonna taco you looking at that
he's gonna belt Oh si holster he's gonna
belt on maybe guarantee you're not
cutting it not it's a tourniquet yeah no
I said I holster you like the carry is
neither the sexiest way who do you think
he do we know his character name I feel
like he's gonna be a new Poe Dameron
where you know I got ya like no I just
mean his character is mostly jacket like
there's no two beyond jacket yeah and
everyone wants the jacket yeah they'll
get it set all our images for today
folks
that's everything that's a wrap well you
know what that means what does it mean
how's your cue and walk off oh okay well
I'm attached to this microphone down you
just hide out a frame okay just crouch
can you validate my parking thing not
the deaf person hold a deaf person okay
just um yeah crouch right behind it okay
careful with the cable be careful
crush lower okay
okay that's perfect all right now it's
time to hear your general grievances
this is from Cal should dare you who
said you are quite a depth out posting
mediocre unfunny content
it started out strong and I clearly need
to read the whole comment before I pick
these I thought it was gonna be positive
one I'm just going to move on to the
next one this is from Hannah poor Rao
and Hannah says do an honest trailer for
Wonder Woman please I don't I don't do
those it's not me who's going to find
that comment here okay let's see what
what else we have
Oh a relevant one to someone who might
have watched the show this is from
toasty OHS and toasty Oh says what's
Jenny's middle name my middle name is
lenio Falcon so my full name is Jenny
lineal Falcon Nicholson
well that's everything goodbye
he's perfect my oh my god I forgot you
were there he scared me
no this puzzle does not smell good why
why I don't know what cameras are on
anymore goodbye farewell big goodbye bye
[Music]